we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p you know
it's not super common that viewers write
in and report their dreams to me it's
also and I mean literally not like their
aspirations but I mean the dreams that
they had while sleeping it's also I
think not super common that people are
dreaming about me but here's a voicemail
that it's very political and it relates
to me and it relates the Trump and it's
a dream that somebody had take a listen
to this I David uh this Jason from
Portland I just wanted to tell you a
dream that I had last night it was
actually kind of funny it was like I was
watching your show and you were telling
us that uh Trump had a heart attack and
that he died how he lived in front of
the TV I I thought that I'd just share
that with you
thanks yeah you know I've actually
thought if ever there were to be a
presidential assassination or death
while the person is president how would
I report it what would it be like and
what would it be like if it's a
president whose policy I'm in favor of
what would it be like if it's a
president whose policies I'm opposed to
and I don't think I could really say
exactly what such a report would be like
but what I can tell you is that I have
never wished death on anybody and every
death is a sad thing for the loved ones
of that individual and I don't know what
it would be like if something were to
happen to Donald Trump while he is
president and it was time for me to to
report it but in any case my guess is it
wouldn't be like this person's dream
that I think I can be pretty sure of
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we will talk about a new report
about the number of jobs that will be
eliminated by automation by 2030 there's
actually a contrarian movement now when
it comes to the automation technological
unemployment issue there's a movement
that it's starting to say we really
don't think it's a problem we don't
actually think that there's going to be
net job loss because of technology
there's a new report from McKinsey which
disagrees and we're going to get into
detail about that on today's bonus show
we will also talk about how dr. Ronnie
Jackson the guy who claimed Trump is six
three and weighs 239 which no person who
has ever seen a picture of Trump
I imagine believes he has now been a
named Donald Trump's chief medical
advisor and assistant should we care
about this is it really up to Trump who
he has advising him on these issues or
is this an issue of public concern all
of those stories and more on today's
bonus show get access to the bonus show
by becoming a member at WWE at medCom or
by becoming a patron at patreon.com
slash david pakman show